What's interesting also about the 1800s
is that same year around the first
Barbar War is around I think 18 or 1801
it starts and but in 1800 Napoleon
enters Egypt or I'm sorry 1798
>> and he easily conquers Egypt. Okay. And
this is known also as kind of the
beginning of the colonial era. So the
colonial era you see Islam go from this
super powerful thing and it starts now
it becomes now Europe is super powerful
technologically militarily economically
and it starts spreading out and
conquering its former foe. People don't
realize this but to the colonial powers
a lot of them saw themselves as
crusaders. They were continuing the war.
I forget his name. Is it Alan B? But
some guy came and uh you know when they
entered and conquered Syria went up to
Saladin's tomb. supposedly and kicked it
and said, "We're back." Meaning, you
know, the Franks or the crusaders are
back.
>> So, to a lot of these Europeans, they
they still understood it that way. But
>> why it happened? I think because is the
Islamic world, as I was kind of telling
you, its entire economy was based on war
and plunder and slave and the slave
system. Okay. They never produced
anything the way Europe eventually went
to, especially technologically and
militarily. Um so I think on once once
any Muslim region power is unable to
conquer and plunder it has no economy
and it starts falling apart and this
happened before. So the Ottoman Empire
still persists
and why does it persist? because it
westernizes whereas the rest of the
Middle East, you know, Egypt and which
was by then sort of run by the Mlukes
and all these other areas are completely
now just spent, you know, uh there's
nothing to plunder, there's no economy,
everything's falling apart. It's very
easily taken over. Uh but but the
Ottomans, they westernized,
>> which is ironic because the Ottomans
were the chief uh you know, standard
bearers of jihad. They actually took to
jihad and articulated it more than the
Arabs, their forebears did. That was
their thing. Okay. And you know under a
turk they actually got rid of the Arabic
script took the Roman alphabet dressed
in Roman I'm sorry not Roman western
attire shave the beards etc etc. So
there everyone became westward looking
including you know the Muslims who could
because that was the way to you know win
and the Islamic way now that it it's it
it kind of spent it became a spent force
at this point and it was kind of an
anacronism really didn't have much kind
of the way it did things was no longer
going to work in this new world with
Europe the way it was and uh so that's
so the colonial era is a very important
thing to keep in mind because uh you
know these It's it's funny too again.
Here we go. The the colonial colonial
era and what happened nowadays is
presented as so horrible. You know,
these evil European white guys going
into you know these countries, not just
Muslim countries, India and colonizing.
But what's funny is if you read the
written the writings of natives from the
colonial era, they talk about it as the
greatest time. This is the time when we
had learning, when we had medicine, when
we had science and technology because
the Europeans also brought this stuff
with them. They did, right? Um whereas,
you know, if you look at places that
Islam conquered, there's places in Spain
where they had that constant war in the
middle, you know, you had the Christians
in the north and that are just until now
like infertile and just totally
devastated. So, at least, you know, the
Europeans brought all this stuff. And
here's an irony. When I think of uh
religion or whatever, someone becoming
conservative and and clinging to the old
ways, I just can't help but think that
through time things become more liberal.
What's happening is actually the
opposite in the Islamic world. If you go
to the Middle East in the 1930s,
way way more liberal and western looking
than anything today. The people weren't
resentful. They were actually trying to
westernize. They dressed like
westerners. They uh the women didn't
have the hijab. They dress they were
decent. Not I don't mean it in a
promiscuous way, but they dressed in
dresses and they looked good. Men were
in suits and ties and they shaved. So
Islam's appeal was it's the strong horse
and if you join us, you get all these
benefits that we were talking about.
>> And once Muslims start seeing that that
wasn't the case, it's really fell by the
wayside.
>> And so that's why I find it ironic if
you look at you would think that, you
know, in 2025 Muslims are going to be
more liberal than in 1925. It's the
exact opposite. And I find that very
interesting and I think it starts going
to where we're headed talking the bigger
talk about you know the modern era and I
believe a lot of that actually has to do
with this that in as much as the west
exuded power and confidence Muslims
followed it and which is human nature
whoever you know whoever's strong or
smarter than you or whatever you can
learn from you're going to try to
emulate and but once the west sort of
started hating itself and promoting
everyone else so let's say in the
whatever 1960s just to give a a rough
date where all of a sudden now you know
it was all how we're it's it the
narrative became Europeans are the
horrible people everyone is great and in
fact Islam is even better and Islam is
what a wonderful religion I think that
actually pushed Muslims back so on the
one hand it actually get made them
disrespect the west naturally so it's
it's very easy to have contempt and
disdain for someone who just disrespects
themselves and and fawns over you that's
just human nature. And it also sort of
made so it made them go back said who
they basically said, "Yeah, you're
right. You're just a bunch of dirty
infidels." So the theory became and it
was very well articulated by an Egyptian
theoretician of the Muslim Brotherhood
Seed Alut who came to America
>> and he was kind of a moderate Muslim.
Then he came to America I think in the
50s and he was just scandalized by how
liberal Americans were and you know men
and women were consorting together etc
etc. So he developed this idea which
became very prominent which is you know
these infidels in the west you can
appropriate and learn from them
technology or science things of this
nature but when it comes to mor to the
greater metaphysical issues religion
certainly we have to stick to Islam and
that was really this is one of the chief
return to Islam. So the idea is yeah we
can learn from them secular
materialistic things but as far as how a
society is governed or structured or how
individuals should live their lives or
even as collectives this is of course
Islam and all the while the west further
promotes that and sponsors that kind of
thinking and uh stifles its own heritage
and this is my point is you see how
that's very different than their
forebears the colonial the the
colonizers the colonizers were
unabashedly proud there's this famous
story I forget his name but
general in India during the colonial era
where they you know he just saw some
ruckus and a bunch of Indians Indian
Indians who were going to burn a woman
alive sati I think it's called where if
if your if a man dies and his woman is
still alive they burn her on his p and
he found out what's going on and he
tried to ban it and they said uh well
this is our custom and etc and he said
okay you do your custom we'll do ours
and our custom is when men burn women
alive we hang them all okay so that kind
of perspective the West had which was
respectable from even from the adversary
whereas now it's completely gone now
it's oh yeah you do whatever you want
you're right your culture is superior
etc etc and this of course continues
till this day and I believe that's what
exacerbates and brings out the worst of
Muslims this is why it's ironic when you
look in the west and in Europe often
times the Muslims who are the most
radical are the second third generation
Muslims and I think a lot of it has to
do with this sort of symbiotic
relationship with sort of western um
self degradation which only provokes
them to fall back more on their own
Islamic heritage and have even more
contempt for Westerners. Even as
Westerners fall over themselves
thinking, "Oh, I need to, you know,
appease him some more. That's how he'll
like me." When it's, of course, doing
the exact opposite.